several biotech companies are beginning
clinical trials now of vaccines and
treatments as the corona virus continues
to spread at unprecedented rates
worldwide for more insight on this we're
gonna bring in former FDA associate
associate commissioner he's also
president of the Center for Medicine in
the public interest
Peter Pitts Peter thanks so much for
joining us today there's this race
across the globe there this race across
the globe to get to a vaccine hearing
different you know officials give us
different numbers different varying
length of time at how far we are out
from that I guess the question that
matters most to Americans is not when
there will be a vaccine but when there
will be a vaccine that is approved for
widespread use what's your best
guesstimate on that now you know there's
a lot of good news here biotech
companies are working with governments
and regulatory agencies and academia all
around the world to get this vaccine
done to get therapeutics invented the
FDA for example in the u.s. is working
24 hours a day 7 days a week really
around the clock making sure that
experimental medicines are getting
through the system that existing
medicines are getting what's called
emergency use exemption so that doctors
have the tools they need to fight for
those people who are the most ill people
in hospital older people people with
pre-existing conditions so we have
things like chloroquine that is both
undergoing solid scientific research as
well as being used in clinic right now
obviously you can't base these things
clearly on anecdote the plural of
anecdote isn't data but we're doing the
right thing when it comes to testing
again similarly whether it's testing
that show positive or negative or
whether it's plasma antibody testing
those tests are being sped forward but
my guess relative to a vaccine is
probably 10 months to a year and for
vaccines that's pretty fast I think
there's pretty solid cause for optimism
well so now there's this race to a
vaccine you say that's 10 to 12 months
out and then there's also these antibody
tests that you mentioned we keep hearing
a lot about them take a listen to dr.
Anthony Fauci a couple of days ago on
these tests they'll get your reaction on
the other side within a period of a week
or so we're gonna have a rather large
number of tests that are available these
antibody tests are tests that we do on
other diseases but they need to be
validated you need to make sure that
they're consistent and that they're
accurate and that's what we're doing now
both with the NIH and with the FDA so
break unpack that a little bit for us
talk to us and real speak about what
this means for Americans well firstly
what dr. Fauci is saying is you don't
want tests approved that are inaccurate
you know you want to expedite but not
rush and that's that's what's happening
right now and that's the finesse and it
takes a team effort both government and
private industry to make sure it's
happening you know and it is but the
importance of these antibody tests is it
doesn't necessarily show whether you're
positive or negative it shows whether or
not you've already had the disease and
that's important really for two main
reasons the first is that the blood
plasma the antibodies from people who've
already come through to the other end of
the tunnel might give patients of a bit
of immunity it might make the courts
that is a little easier to handle
equally important it'll give us an idea
how many Americans have already had the
disease and that's a key data point
relative to when we can reopen our
economy there's this continuing saga for
lack of a better word with
hydroxychloroquine President Trump keeps
touting it in the taskforce briefings as
a viable treatment he wants more people
to start using it but a lot of medical
experts say it hasn't been tested enough
it's been tested but not clinically
what's your take on that the data that's
out there right now is purely anecdotal
you know there's no real solid science
behind it that you can build a
foundation on but we're collecting it
should it be used I think that doctors
have the option now to use it for their
patients but an important point here is
this is a medicine that's also being
used for patients with chronic
conditions such as lupus and rheumatoid
arthritis so we don't want to cause
shortages we don't want people to rush
out and demand these drugs 85% of people
that petkovic 19 will ride it out at
home in bed with plenty of liquids with
tender loving care and they won't need
chloric when they shouldn't ask for it
doctors have this as a tool for the most
seriously ill patients who are in
hospital will really need
to survive so it sounds like risks there
with using hydroxychloroquine are not
just to the to the users but concerns
about causing a shortage for other
medical patients who rely on it to stay
healthy themselves independently of
kovat 19 in the coronavirus peter pits
thanks so much for your time and your
expertise today we appreciate it
my pleasure to stay safe shelter in
place